today
i'm doing a
exploration
of kasparov chess
and i want to start by thanking kasparov
chess for sponsoring the stream
and eventual youtube video i'm usually
super hesitant when it comes to doing
sponsored content
on stream
but uh
this is a site and like the content
within the site i don't think
so many people are aware of
and i have full access to show whatever
i want they have all these like training
programs
and
a lot of like training videos combined
with puzzles
so
we have the kasparov chess command
with more information on
the offer that's going on
it's coupon code rusin
to save 50 off get a seven day free
trial
and if you do a
uh a paid annual membership you get a
free signed copy
of kasparov's how life imitates chess
excise sparks asking who is the book
signed by
it's signed by kasparov
himself not signed by me unfortunately
i think that would be a little bit less
valuable
okay let's dive in
let's start with an overview there's a
lot of different things to explore
there's a whole kasparov master class
which is 57 episodes
there's programs which are structured
based on your level
and then there's a whole lessons library
too
which i think i'll spend most of the
time going into
uh but let's do some warm-up
i could probably use some puzzles after
after that viewer tournament missing a
lot of tactics
and um
yeah the way that the site kind of
operates is
there's all these different levels
starting with beginner
going all the way up to master
this is how the lesson video content is
structured as well
and
beginner is supposed to be sub 1000 and
then there's 200 point increments so
casual is like around 1200 1400
1618 etc
man we could do a lot of different types
of puzzles
let's do random
maybe we'll do one of each
i'll let twitch chat also
maybe uh
chime in here
black to move this is the easiest tactic
in chess
white just played rookie one attacking
the queen
and yeah the reading the raiding ranges
are meant to like stretch your ability
so the 1200 rated puzzle
is intended to take some
to take a 1200 player some work to solve
yeah queen jc1 simplest tactic in chess
is taking a free piece
okay so uh
we we account we accomplished beginner
let's do casual
here's the sound effects
okay black to move
this is combining the easiest tactic in
chess
with uh
with a different tactic
a lot of people saying fork
okay so there's knight f3
but if we play knight f3
uh there's bishop takes f3 so let's not
get any problems wrong just to begin
with
uh yeah queen jake's bishop checking the
king and then uh
then we deliver this case a triple fork
gg
yeah so i guess if we want to
keep upping the level go back
do club level
okay at least most of chat seems pretty
sharp
bishop to a3 wait oh it's our move
okay so we're probably taking the bishop
but then pawn b4
if this were a game it's the type of
position you just take the bishop right
away like there's no reason to calculate
um if we don't take the bishop white's
losing so let's take the bishop
and now this is very important
where does the knight go
so the most important thing is to stop
the past pawns
if knight c4 then a3
i don't think we're stopping the
the a pawn
[Music]
if we play knight c2 then i think we're
blockading everything
yeah knight c2 b3 knight a3 everything's
located
lights up a piece
nice
oh it keeps going
okay the bishop wants to capture on d in
d3 so we play bishop e2
[Music]
and now everything's good
[Music]
gaining some puzzle rating
[Music]
okay that was club
so far so good with the speed run
white to move
black's last move was king c8
as we're going to see they're gonna get
much more difficult
like already there's not anything
obvious hanging
white does want to exploit some of the
the targets in black's position i mean
queen g7
queen g7 hits the rook but the rook can
move
i'm wondering if can white just take on
d5
knight takes d5 queen takes d5 and then
rook b6
it doesn't seem so convincing though
queen e5 yeah queen e5 actually looks
much nicer it's a type of position
there's a lot of different ideas
but queen e5 hitting the rook and
hitting e6 pawn
uh i'm gonna try queen e5 i think this
is most convincing
[Music]
although then there's knight cheese no
knight g6 rook takes g6
removing the defender of the rook
and now we take
there we go
okay so upping the level
oh that was league okay so this was sub
a thousand
a thousand to twelve hundred twelve
hundred fourteen hundred oh that was
fourteen hundred to 1600
now tournament i believe is 1600 to
1800.
and again where we're doing random
puzzles so
uh we're getting all different types of
themes
first question is which way are the
pawns going we're playing black
promoting this way
uh this looks like some kind of study
position
the bishop wants to
i mean bishop's preventing pawn b2
yeah knight c4 looks like the the easy
choice
just preparing pawn b2
[Music]
knight c4 there's f4
wait a minute knight c4 f4 b2 takes
takes and then f
f5
we don't want to trade pawns so g5 f6
ah this is a nice one and then we we
play either we probably played knight c4
there f7 knight e5
yeah unfortunately i i can't oh can i
draw arrows oh i can't draw arrows okay
i didn't know i could draw arrows
okay so
we want to play b2 to prepare we play
knight c4 white's going to try and trade
off the f pawn
and then b2
takes takes
f5
and then g5
and then after
f6 it looks logical to play king g6 but
then f7 and
black has to take the pawn and lose a g5
pawn
so it's really important to see them i
can come back
to
c4
and then after f7 knight e5 attacks the
knight and the the pawn or the the king
and the
the pawn
uh so let's do it
g5
yeah i guess after f6 there's also
knight e6
or um knight t3 preparing
the the other um
other way to get to e5
we're moving up we got three more levels
so advanced
is 1800 to 2000.
here we go oh it's messy
gotta stay focused here all the rooks
are hanging
except for this rook
um when it comes to tackling a position
like this
first we want to count material
the material is actually equal here
and then it's a matter of considering
the candidate moves i mean we can move
the rook anywhere safe and then still
have both rooks attacked
so one question is what is the
difference between a move like this and
move like this
i mean it seems most tempting to play
rook d3
aligning
with the bishop and knight
actually rook d3 looks like the most
convincing because then
in some cases we just win a full rook
if rookie a white's actually getting
compensation with bishop f4 yeah we win
one of the rooks but white holds on to
the c pawn
yeah i'm waiting for chad to come up
with some some logic but i think i've
explained it
at least to the best of my ability
like rook d3
because when we take one of the rooks
we're attacking the bishop that's
undefended
so one line is bishop
c2 or c4 but then we take a rook and
we're up a piece
and then the bishop takes on d3 we get
the pawn to d3
let's do it rook d3
oh now which rook do we take
could take on
on e1 or a1
intuitively should probably take in the
center
just because when our bishop's on e1
we're going to have a pawn d2 in the end
as some idea
and we also don't want to leave the rook
on the open e file
let's do it
and then take
okay
a nice one
we'll do two more and then i want to get
to the the video library
so expert is 2000 to 2200
a master is 2200 plus
okay i i think i think this one is
easier than
i would have expected
but actually maybe there's a couple a
couple options for black
yeah a couple people spotting the free
knight
but then our knights also hanging whoa
but then the queen is hanging
wait a minute
it's a choice between rook takes d4 or
queen takes g3
and rook d4 and bishop c5 looks pretty
nice for black
but the way these puzzles work there's
only one correct solution
so this is a case where we have to
compare the options and then try and see
white's resources
yeah i'm drawn to rook d4 more because
it hits the queen
and then prepares this knight's still
hanging
[Music]
and the only way for the queen to defend
the knight
is to move here here and then still
bishop c5
with nasty discoveries
but there's also some reason like queen
g3 we we do keep the pin alive and we're
still threatening this
oh i forgot to count the material that's
a really good point blocks down a piece
here
so it's not just about winning back a
piece it's about
winning more material
yeah so i guess if if queen takes aft or
queen takes g3 there's queen f2
i think that just defends everything for
white
but rook d4 queen f2 bishop d5
it's gotta be
what would gary do
hopefully gary would play this move
about to play it
okay so now the question is why is rook
d4
not working
and here's actually here's
it's kind of a lack of a feature but
it's also a feature of the site there's
no stockfish
so it forces us to think
to think on our own
um
now we could try again
we could also ask for a hint
but why is rook t4
ah queen f2 and queen takes f6
is some idea
and then we're not left with any
discoveries actually queen f2 bishop c5
queen f6 if queen g3 we get mated
let's see
queen takes g3
but queen takes g3 queen f2
should we ask for a hint
i actually don't know what this button
does
let's see
we move the knights
wow
no one considered any night move
this is the askgary bun yeah
knight g4
it's a plot twist
here here we see the the difficulty like
this is
this is a very high level exercise
and it's probably about just fully
maximizing
[Music]
the activity
knight g4 is crazy actually though
because we're hitting we're hitting the
pawn we're also taking away these
squares
the knights still hit and there's still
threats of this
on top of all of that
the knight is pinned to the h2 square
because we have the bishop controlling
f1
so there's cases where like if white
allows queen h2 we're just like
absolutely mating
so it's not just about winning material
it's not even about winning material
it's about
just not taking material
and realizing the fact that
we can just overpower the opponent
okay pawnee five
and now rook d4
probably rook d4 we don't want to take
on h6 because then we don't have bishop
c5 as a move
rook d4 almost traps a queen too
like the queen has to move here or here
or there and then we win the queen
okay
so this is this goes to show the level
of difficulty like
um and that was
that was expert level
now i will i will share i tried master
[Music]
level puzzles
a couple days ago
and
the few that i tried it was like two or
three puzzles i i did not get a single
one correct
so here we go
um
this is really intended for
like serious title players
good luck to chat yeah
all right so let's uh
let's apply some
some sort of structured thought process
to this position
counting material it is equal
uh immediate attacks or threats of
course uh
the bishop on e7 attacked twice
defended three times
there's also the potential rook takes g8
um so we probably want to consider like
all the captures
i'm going to take a moment before liking
a chat
just to think uh think on my own without
too much influence
we take on g8 take on e7 it's one big
trade
oh f7 is also a target though
okay i'll look at chats
any ideas rook takes g8
i'm looking at irene's suggestion first
knight takes e7 queen takes f7
that looks really obvious actually
wait f7 is just hanging
i think i'll try this
so i just don't see a defense for black
if it's wrong we'll try and figure out
why
queen f7
okay it keeps going
black threatening uh
some really annoying
perpetual
i'm thinking h3 here
h3 seems like such a chill
like simple move
and then black's completely stuck
there's also king g2
is there a difference between h3 and
king g2
king g2 just avoids checks entirely
but king g2 allows this move
and then queen e4 with check
there's also i see bishop takes e7 but
again queen d1 check and
the problem
if we
especially if we move our bishop to
saturn there's no getting out of checks
so
[Music]
let's go for
let's go for
i h3 h3 we have to use some intuition
too here
hey okay h3 is solved
um
h3 is not a type of move you see in
in puzzles too often
uh
it's funny like
gage three came to me quicker than the
initial like 97 queen f7
also this move is very near and dear to
my heart
but i played this move in the final
round of the
national high school championship in
2011.
it's a move that won me the title
anyway um i'm gonna
switch gears here
so that was a puzzle trainer
but i think that the biggest draw to the
site
is
just the video content in general
now they do have a play zone there
there's a few other like features
um
it's not active i probably wouldn't
recommend playing
in the play zone because it's it's going
to be hard to find opponents
and even though this is a sponsored
stream i can still
point out some of the uh
deficiencies in the site
but um i do want to focus on
the video content
and yeah i won't be playing people on
the site
uh so one maybe we can do the daily
lesson
we got maurice
they have about a dozen
different like strong players doing
video lessons from them
including geary and
maurice
and mvl
okay so it's daily lesson time
the g3
i assume this is g3 g6
sacrifice here we can see black has
offered a trade of bishops
in order to control the dark squares
white decided
well
why not just take a rook on f8
and was punished brutally by the move
bishop to e3 check okay now first of all
you cannot play king to f1 because queen
comes to h4 and
the threat of queen to f2 mate is
unstoppable well you can only play g3
but that allows queen to h3 mate or even
bishop to h3 with checkmate so the king
had to go into the corner with king to
h1 and now the crispy knight to g3 with
check that has to be accepted and now
queen takes on f8 and here comes the
queen to the eight six square to deliver
the deadly blow
a knight draw back to f1 but after queen
h6 check knight to h2 king to g7 the
game is now over as a rook is headed to
h8 and the queen will take on h2 and
nothing at all can stop that maneuver
in this next position black should have
been very careful
b4 would have been a nice move looking
to trade off queens instead black played
the unbelievably greedy queen to f2
trying to take the pawn on g3 while
white punished this move instantly with
the move f5
clearing the line for the queen to come
in and hunt down the black king
okay generally uh
there's no need to pause these videos
but f5 is the type of move you should
play and then see
the resulting combination
of course you can take with the g pawn
if you like but that's gonna just open
up the king to this brilliant sacrifice
bishop takes on e6 and that's gonna be
all she wrote the queen could take on e6
and then f5 continuing the attack or
even play knight to g5 in this position
where trading off pieces does not help
in trying to block because the queen
will just ravage your pieces on the
queen side
instead black played e takes on f5 and
white crashed through with queen to
eight six check king to ga there you go
and now queen takes on g6 with check
this pawn is pinned to the king and if
the king runs and queen takes f7 is mate
but after h takes rook takes h8 king to
g7
rook down to eight seven
checkmate
if you're going to be greedy in chess
make sure you don't get killed okay
that's good life advice
now
uh now we have the exercises
um i already did this at some point
but we we can do it
i'll let chat do it let's see if chat
can uh
learn from the few examples
and solve these puzzles
yeah it kind of sounded like a boxing
match there
or a fast food outing
and yeah it does help when knowing the
theme like when doing the random puzzles
earlier
then it's kind of just you have to take
all the
all the patterns you've studied into
consideration but here we know the theme
is taking or stacking on g6
so and the calculation is pretty
straightforward here
i take on f6 take on g6
and then actually sack again and black's
gonna be left with a naked king
ooh
bishop g7 or rook f6
rook f6
the bishop g7 there's bishop takes g7
and white's not mating
but this wins back material
[Music]
yeah that was almost zack sack mate that
was sack sack and then beat up material
next exercise
okay so we know the focal point
this is g3 pawn
but how to actually make the
ideas work in this position
i see o king gali saying bishop to c5
yeah bishop d5 looks really nice
we start by pinning the knight
and if bishop to e3
that blocks the queen from defending g3
then knight takes g3
and i think white's whole position is
about to crumble
bishop c5 bishop e3 knight takes g3
takes takes if king f1 there's rook
takes f2 with a ventral mate not to
mention if the king goes this way
there's potential for the rook to swing
over
uh let's start with
yeah let's start with bishop's e5
rook f2 is also a consideration but
after king f2
i mean we we lose one of our most
valuable pieces
and we're better off pinning the knight
rather than
capturing right away
and then takes
oh
okay there's a lot of discoveries here
got knight e4
winning box of material
in this case i guess just winning the
night we can also win the bishop
oh we could take with rook on on f2 as
well
wait a minute
there's choices
brook takes f2 looks like the most
appetizing
the most crispy
because if bishop takes f2 then we we
forkmate
and now this bishop's hanging
okay
that was exercise two
so yeah some of these are actually
pretty complex puzzles
but it does help to know the theme
and again we know the theme irene
suggesting h4h5
i think this one if i didn't know the
theme i would not find the right move
like maybe even in a tournament game
but knowing the theme it should make it
a bit easier to find and yeah white can
be really direct here
bishop takes g6 right away
and this is very forcing the black has
to take back it takes this way it's uh
there's queen e6
and then king f8
you'd imagine white's having all the fun
there at the very least there's queen e7
bishop t7
and white has won two pawns in that line
and then if pawn takes
then queen h3 threatening mate
f pawn moves queen takes e6 and it's
gonna be the same line
if f5 we play queen h8 king f7
and the queen is cleaning up
okay one more puzzle
no two more puzzles
oh okay this is a crispy one this is
what uh
almost exactly what maurice showed
earlier
same idea different position
[Music]
knight g3
some people might like be inclined to
set up but knight g3 is way more forcing
and it's so important to understand that
after pawn takes
there's no defense to king g7 rookie
chait like even though white has a move
okay maybe trying to trade off the
bishop
um
this is so powerful to control these two
squares
and
gigi
okay final exercise
oh this is different this time there's
no opponent pawn
in this case on g3
okay a lot of crazy moves being
suggested rook h3
queen h3
there's also 92
yeah knight e2 is actually really
forcing like some of these other moves
like knight f3
it's not entirely clear if black's
achieving much even if we win g4 with
check
f2 is defendable in these lines
and i saw some suggestions for rook h3
as well
i think in that line there's rook a3
no a4k392
wait okay rook h3
takes takes
uh well white can take on d4 there and
kill all of that's fun
so we gotta make use of our knight
before white can take it
there is some suggestion for knight e2
king f1 knight g3
which actually looks pretty promising
because after pawn takes queen h1
skewering the king to the rook
uh if ki moves up we take the rook if he
moves to e2 we take on g2 and then the
rook is coming in really kill
so i hope that makes sense
i don't think rook h3 works
because takes takes
and takes
let's do 92.
and this aligns with the theme we're
sacking on g3
and the the recurring theme is basically
destruction of
the the pawn shelter
like even though this is slightly
different than the other ones
we're taking away the shelter from the
king
and then k take
up the exchange here
gg
that was a more difficult one there
there were some lines that also looked
attractive
i had to
eliminate
um but that's the point like the the
later exercises are far more difficult
and they are intended to stretch one's
ability
okay i want to move on i want to show
probably the main
like
the most powerful part of the site
the programs are structured
video series based on what your level is
so
i don't think i i
want to spend the time actually watching
through like full series
but um
for any beginners out there if you want
like a structured program
these are
super well organized very highly
produced
and
they they share a lot of uh like key
fundamentals
what you need to
like be a decent chess player
to access this there are paid
memberships but with the current offer
you can use coupon code rosen for a
seven day free trial
and get get access to all the video
content on the site
um i'm open to
also just going through and sharing what
chat wants
but it's it's a very similar model to
netflix is
yeah you you
you get a membership and then you you
have access to watch uh hundreds
of hours of video content
uh the other really cool thing is we can
sort based on what we're looking for
so someone was asking about strategy
like if we can walk through a strategy
video
and we can select the level
i think it's fine to like keep all
levels just see what's uh what's
available
and then we can also filter through the
teacher
so i i don't have any uh
any content on this site
um because i'm primarily focused on my
own content
but there's uh there's a lot of notable
coaches and gm's and
uh chess content creators here
entering a tactic tactical league of
your own
yeah so it's basically like a mini
course on a certain theme
uh starting with wait
starting with gary
what are tactics ah it's scary if not
the soul of chess
the heart
the technical definition sounds boring
forcing sequence of moves to achieve a
concrete result but tactics are much
more
they are the action
and reaction of chess the punch and
counter punch
the beauty
and the brains
for me
tactics are the lifeblood of the game
it's always action
and it's always surprise
and it's very natural for any beginner
because it's easy to understand and
appreciate
for centuries
chess fans have been mesmerized
by the beautiful combinations
and tactical shots and he's watching so
much passion i've been called immortal
evergreen because
they were full of tactics and tactics
are always accompanied by
sacrifice
and
we we always enchanted to see the
triumph of spirit over material okay
let's let's get to the testing it feels
boring so that's uh the taste of like
the production value
uh daily diet
we could hop around
this is tanya
this might be tanya
[Music]
our first example is between two very
strong i should see if tanya has any
opening content on the site
i got a sense of her opening preparation
and masters playing with the white
pieces is check now i'm going to turn
off subtitles
one grandmaster david navarra and with
the black pieces 16 year old
indian super talent grandmaster nehal
serene
this was played in the banter blitz cup
and here david made the move g4
now at first sight it looks like
something has gone very wrong for black
as this move forks the queen and the
knight a double attack but this weakens
a critical f4 square
did nehal miss this or is there a way
that black can make use of this weakness
on f4
turns out nehal is a very tricky kid and
he had a counter blow of his own
starting with rook e2
removing a key defender and white has to
recapture on e2 and now black jumps in
with the knight to f4
forking the king and the queen
king
david also has to capture the queen but
now the unfortunate position of the rook
after knight c1 nehal ends up with an
extra piece david navarra resigned gigi
our next example okay um
again i'm trying to give a taste of some
of the video content
i'm actually really curious about the
opening content
because i get the questions so often of
like openings what openings i recommend
for various levels
um
okay
we're moving on to openings
oh wow they have a whole opening for
newbies
wait
tanya
oh no open content from tanya
aronian
mvl
okay got some some content from mvl and
geary
oh and uh elizabeth pets
why i played in a previous uh speedchest
championship
okay let's watch a geary video
let's hear geary talk about openings d4
with the move f5
now the opening has been around for
years
oh wow okay
okay i didn't realize this this is like
within sidelines there's dutch
there's albin counter gambit and there's
budapest gambit
what does chat want to watch we'll have
time for one
buddha is winning i kind of want to
watch budapest too i want to see a super
grand master's take
on the budapest
might not watch the whole thing but i
just want to get a sense of what he says
and the budapest gambit is an opening
that can play against first move one d4
after knight f6 uh c4
the pawn sacrifice with e5 is called the
budapest gambit it's been around for
years and been played by uh some of the
strong modern players as well by shahir
mahmoud yaroff many many times many
other grand masters badou but
as well um after gtx e5 which is um
obviously the only way to capture the
spawn
um black should play knight g4 there is
also a
remarkably
well publicized and known variation
knight e4
uh i believe this
probably has some traps to it but uh
after the movie this is called the fajr
words variation this is actually
something stopping any bishop before
business
i couldn't find that many traps
black
white should probably know that queen d5
is not ideal because knight c5 then the
queen will get trapped in the corner
bishop b7
okay he's going through this really
quickly but if queen digs a knight c6
and uh it's actually a nice one c7 then
knight c6 so um 25 not very good but uh
simple knight f3 followed by g3 just
gives white uh a pawn advantage and uh
another way of playing perhaps after a3
knight c6 knight f3 d6 can be met uh
with a very strong move quincy too and
this gives white a uh enormous advantage
i believe so an idea for um a little bit
of a bluff
okay so far are you showing how to
repeat the passage variation and
the problem for black is that uh
even if he takes this pawn back which he
which he eventually will as well just
enjoy a small plus due to his control of
the center for example with a move like
even even a simple move like e3 knight
takes e5 and now for example knight h3
intending knight f4
this pawn structure in general gives
white a small plus it has a little bit
more space um that say black has a
reasonable position so um
there are some lines i should mention
there is a uh aggressive line with e4
knight x e5 and f4 uh black uh
black can fight fight back here but this
uh an interesting variation that
probably gives white a small advantage
as well objectively a few other lines
main
main move is bishop f4 after knight f3
black can play bishop c5 closing this
bishop and after e3 play the move knight
c6 and in these variations uh there is
an interesting
idea interesting motif that
both white and black players okay i'm
going to take a guess he's going to
point out rook a6
way forward so let's have to bishop e2
why it really cannot hang on to the
spawn
and now it's actually called the castle
castle rook 8
knight c3 wait is this 2x speed he is
talking about fast
this is not 2x speed this is normal
speed
but this is how gary talks
it's actually nice you you could slow it
down
we could hear geary at 0.5 speed
and knight e5 965 965
it's
quite important to know that
sometimes black postpones the move
and the idea is that after
you have trouble keeping up
a5
uh let's say natural movement i don't
know if black were to play d6 white uh
would have once again destruct the
structure in the center of the c4 pawn
that guards the d5 square gives white a
small plus he will eventually prepare
the move for four but black has a
cunning little idea that's uh
very very common uh for this uh budapest
gamut this rook a6 uh
nice
very good
uh yeah rogue a6 actually leads a lot of
fun ideas
um
yeah he goes through things that are
pretty fast-paced so this may be
geared towards
uh
someone who can follow along
it looks like this is more of like a
synopsis like these are
the key lines from a grand master's
perspective and then it's worth digging
into them
a bit more closely
if you're just tuning in
we have been
taking a look at kasparovchest.com
kind of poking around at all the video
lessons
uh various topics different coaches
we do have a promotion going on
if you use coupon code rosen
and we let me see if the
i'm logged in right now but i think the
the link will work for me
so if you go to uh yeah it's kasparov
chess.com upgrade account
and
uh this is where
[Music]
you'll see the breakdown
um
the promotion currently
is
you save fifty percent using coupon code
rosen you get a seven day free trial
and
if you do yearly
and then proceed to like do the paid
membership
then you get a pre-signed copy of
kasparov's imitate or how life imitates
chess
uh there's a question how much does it
cost
so if you do yearly it's another 30
percent
let me make sure let's see if i can
actually do this
so basically here is where you you put
your coupon code
rosen
and then
yeah this is 60 off the annual
membership
uh so it's it's 59.99
and again it's seven day free trial if
you don't cancel after seven days you do
get charged
the 59.99
but then then you have access to all the
video content and then you can
get the the signed book too
i was told i think there's there's 140
hours of like program content
and then additional
like special features
i didn't even show the watch tab earlier
but there's a
there's like these documentary
kind of mini series
that
i'll just show it exists it's it's very
highly produced
uh footage like they've had
kind of behind the scenes of mvl
during grand chess tour events
and
[Music]
yeah
the best thing to compare this site to
is basically netflix but for chess
yeah when you sign up for the annual
membership and then
and then your purchase goes through
you'll receive an email to uh
to submit your your shipping information
for the book
um this is something that's being
promoted with my
my uh
my sponsorship basically so
it's only using coupon code rosen do you
get this uh this book offer
oh and because kasparov chess is
actually in the chat too answering
questions so
um
i doubt that's a real gary but maybe it
could be
shout out to gary
and yeah i didn't have a chance to show
they do broadcast all the grand chess
tour games as well in like a different
interface
that uh
it might be easier to actually see like
the results here than elsewhere
they have all the live leader or live
yeah leaderboard and scoring
fishy anan crushing it recently
and yes the book is shipped worldwide
got confirmation from kasparov chess
so even if you're not
in the u.s
if you're located in europe or
[Music]
probably also asia
they are shipping worldwide
are there good live lessons
um
i think a sparta of chess has like an
archive of all the live streams
yeah there's there's been a lot of the
like coaches and gm's live streaming on
on the site
and they're all archived here
oh yeah there's also the podcast too
podcast is free actually
um on apple podcasts
these days there's a lot of chess
podcasts but this kind of details
kasparov's early journey
baby kasparov
i will say like uh it's actually nice
the fact that i
i get a free account thanks to
uh the sponsored stream but
um
i'm probably probably going to watch
more kasparov chess on netflix
in the coming uh days and weeks
because i forgot my netflix password
and there's all this content about geary
talking about ai and like how to use
machines optimally
now if you're watching in the future on
youtube
i'm gonna condense this whole stream
down into a more watchable version
we'll probably have some of the
highlights
of me doing the puzzles
doing the maurice lesson reacting to
gary and anish and mvl
uh for those watching in the future on
youtube
[Music]
i'm going to timestamp everything in
the video description so you can hop
around to various moments
if you want to skip to like the budapest
part
or the the puzzle solving
youtube will be
hopefully a bit more digestible